[Music]
all systems of oppression are highly
adaptive and they can adapt to
challenges and incorporate them they can
allow for exceptions and I think the
most effective adaptation of the system
of racism to the challenges of the civil
rights movement was to reduce a racist
to a very simple formula a racist is an
individual always an individual not a
system who consciously does not like
people based on race must be conscious
and who intentionally seeks to be mean
to them individual conscious intent and
if that is my definition of a racist
then your suggestion that anything I've
said are done is racist or has a racist
impact I'm gonna hear that as you just
said I was a bad person you just put me
over there in that category and most of
my bias anyway is unconscious so I I'm
not intending I'm not aware so now I'm
gonna need to defend my moral character
and and I will and we've all seen it it
seems to be virtually impossible based
on that definition for the average white
person to look deeply at their
socialization to look at the
inevitability of internalizing racist
biases developing racist patterns and
having investments in the system of
racism which is pretty comfortable for
us and serves us really well I think
that definition of a racist that
either/or what I call the good bad
binary is the root of virtually all
white defensiveness on this topic
because it makes it virtually impossible
to talk to the average white person
about the inevitable absorption of a
racist worldview that we get by being
literally swimming in racist water so
let me connect that to myself as a
result of being raised as a white person
in this society I have a racist
worldview
I have a deep racist biases I have
developed racist patterns and I have
investments in the system of racism
because it's it served me really well
it's comfortable it's helped me
overcome the up the barriers that I do
face and I also have an investment of
not seeing any of that for what it would
suggest to me about my identity and what
it would require of me right
I didn't choose any of that I don't feel
guilty about it it is an inevitable
result of being raised in this society
in which racism is the bedrock the
question of guilt comes in in what am i
doing about that while we who are white
tend to be fragile in that it doesn't
take much to upset us around race the
impact of our response is not fragile at
all it's a kind of weaponized
defensiveness weaponized hurt feelings
right and it functions really really
effectively to repel the challenge and
as a white person I moved through the
world racially comfortable virtually
24/7 it is exceptional for me to be
outside of my racial comfort zone and
most of my life I've been warned not to
go outside my racial comfort zone and so
on the rare occasion when I am
uncomfortable racially it's it's a kind
of throwing off of my racial equilibrium
and I need to get back into that and so
I will do whatever it takes to repel the
challenge and get back into it and in
that way I think white fragility
functions as a kind of white racial
bullying to be frank we make it so
miserable for people of color to talk to
us about our inevitable and often
unaware racist patterns that we cannot
help develop from being socialized into
a culture in which racism is the bedrock
and the foundation we make it so
miserable for them to talk to us about
it that most of the time they don't
write just and we just have to
understand that most people of color
that are working or living in primarily
white environments take home way more
daily slights and hurts and insults than
they bother talking to us about because
they're experiencing
they're going to risk more punishment
they're going to lose the relationship
they're going to have their experience
minimized explained away they're going
to cause the person to feel attacked or
hurt and in that way white fragility
functions as a kind of everyday white
racial control none of that has to be
intentional or conscious but that is how
it functions and it's actually
incredibly liberating and transformative
to start from the premise that of course
I've internalized all of this and then I
can stop defending deflecting denying
hoping you won't notice
minimizing explaining and I can just let
go of that and get to work
and there's a question that's never
failed me in my efforts to unpack how do
we pull this off how do so many of us
who are white individually feel so free
of racism and yet we live in a society
that is so profoundly separate and
unequal by race and the question that's
never failed me is not is this true or
is this false is this right or is this
wrong but how does it function how do
these narratives that I tell how do they
function when I tell you well I'm just
an individual why can't we all just be
individuals when I tell you I was taught
to treat everyone the same when I tell
you but it's focusing on race that
divides us when I tell you but I have
lots of friends of color those
narratives have not changed our outcome
and they function to take race off the
table and to exempt the person from any
further engagement and in doing that
they function to protect the current
racial hierarchy in the white position
within it it doesn't have to be what I'm
intending to do but it is the impact of
those narratives
[Music]